[Musique]
donc
ah [
Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
une façon simple d'y penser est si votre
journée normale consiste à
nager 100 miles dans l'océan et maintenant
vous nagez
75  pieds et c'est toute votre existence,
c'est tellement un environnement contre nature que
vous pouvez l'habiller, vous pouvez le faire ressembler à un
bleu et à l'océan, mais c'est un fait d'
être un animal errant social,
euh, puis contraint dans
une baignoire
et donc je pense que c'est psychologique
physiologique euh
vous savez l'impact vraiment
tout le monde veut savoir si l'utilisation d'un
dauphin animatronique
est différente de l'utilisation d'un vrai dauphin
la différence est que vous n'avez pas à faire d'
élevage d'animaux
vous n'avez pas à avoir de programmes d'élevage
vous n'avez pas à vous
inquiéter  à propos de la sécurité avec les êtres humains
et vous pouvez utiliser votre imagination pour
imaginer des types entièrement différents d'
expériences éducatives et de divertissement pour les
animaux pour
le faire, il ne s'agit pas seulement d'
acrobaties
[Musique] me
comprenez-vous
je le savais le parc marin  l'industrie a en
quelque sorte perdu de l'argent consécutivement
décennie par décennie au cours des dernières
décennies
pour de nombreuses raisons il y a un moyen de le
réimaginer nous voyons
des spectacles acrobatiques depuis près d'un demi-
siècle maintenant
imaginez ce qui se passerait si des animaux
qui ne pourraient jamais être  dans de grands aquariums
sont venus de
grands requins blancs des dragons fantastiques qui
pourraient sortir de l'eau et cracher du
feu
des animaux jurassiques avec lesquels vous pourriez nager
et découvrir
ce monde ce n'est pas seulement des dauphins
c'est aussi tout ce que votre
imagination peut vous proposer